und genau das ist einfach das was mich
so richtig ankommt ich meine klar in
deutschland eher spannungsfeld kannst
von jedem die meinung haben die du haben
willst aber bitte habt dann auch die
eier im relax um hinzugehen und ihm das
gleiche sagen was du im internet zu ihm
sagen würdest
willkommen beim ein video im ich habe
mir für heute mal ein etwas ernstes
thema raus und das bedrückt mich
wirklich schon mega lange ich verstehe
einfach nicht was in köpfen dieser
menschen vorgehen war wo man so was
machen muss ich weiß nicht was diese
leute dazu bringt da will ich gerne
heute man bisher mit euch zu bereden
also was ich da so konkret meine ihr
könnt auch geld eurem anstellen lässt
und in die kommentare schreiben wenn ihr
irgendwas anders jeder so schreibt das
direkt in die kommentare ich will wieder
mega viel lesen
also macht es auf jeden fall wenn ihr
meine meinung sein könnt ihr auch gerne
daumen nach oben lassen aber jetzt
fangen wir erstmal und es würde mich
natürlich freuen wenn er bis zum ende
schauen würdet und wirklich im
allgemeinen dazu in den kommentaren
lagers habe ich jetzt schon zum dritten
mal gesagt keine ahnung
auf jeden fall fahren wir erstmal ganz
ich würde sagen allgemein beispiel an
das hab ich denke die meisten von euch
werden ihnen kennen das ist gerade in
facebook halbseitig mal und zwar dieser
hans entertainment dieser etwas ständige
typ der wirklich jeden tag sein leben
eskaliert und irgendwelche fotos oder
videos der forst geht auf facebook
gerade mega der hype um und die vereine
noch märchen mit gefällt mir passiert
ist wirklich ein richtig cooler typ
er unterhält einfach die leute
allerdings gibt's tolle sache die ich
einfach nicht verstehe und leute wissen
einfach nicht was man damit so einem
menschen erhalte ich meine er zum
beispiel vor kurzen video gepostet mit
seiner freundin er hat jetzt irgendwie
ne freundin hat wieder gekürzt und
gesagt dass ihr zusammen hängt ja also
einfach ein video dazu eigentlich alles
cool nichts besonderes was heißt nichts
besonders er kann ich natürlich denken
dass dieses video mega abgehen wird und
mega die runde machen wir das klar aus
einem grund den ich nicht verstehe wenn
ich mir die kommentare unter seinen
videos durch lesetag klar manche
kommentare sind lustig oder so aber
irgendwann wird auch einfach zu hart ich
meine dieses video hat irgendwie 4
millionen klicks oder so auf facebook
was eine enorme zahl ist ihm million
klicks 4 millionen klicks ist krass viel
wenn wir einfach so darüber nachdenke
ich meine vier millionen menschen das ja
nicht wenig und an diesem
gibt's auch einen kommentar den ich
letztens gefunden habe oder der wagen
habe ich schon entfernt
er hat mich ich verstehe nicht wie man
was man sich dabei denkt und kommentar
zu verfassen
und vor allem was man sich dabei denken
diesen kommentar zu leiten und zwar
stadt irgendwo einen tag oder so keine
ahnung wenn ihr diesen hans
entertainment wenn seine freundin
aussieht wie sein zwillingsbruder dieser
kommentar hat 68 1527 likes ja das heißt
er wird den kommentar zu 1000 prozent
gelesen haben und die kommentare unter
seinen videos bestehen wirklich
ausschließlich fast wirklich nur aus
solchen kommentaren
da denke ich mir ist nicht klar was ihr
dabei eine menschen anrichtet ich meine
es ist einfach nur ein typ der da videos
ins netz stellt seine likes bekommt
damit sein leben finanzieren kannst du
zeit was ist daran schlecht ich verstehe
nicht wie man sich so weiter ansteigen
kann ich meine ist zunächst der ball
klar ist ein bisschen dicker oder so
könnt ihr euch nicht vorstellen wie es
bei einem menschen so ankommt einfach
nur seine hague will im internet zu
kriegen
mit wirklich nur beleidigungen so dann
zweifelt man natürlich auch nur noch an
sich selber und wenn das dann auch seine
freundin übertragen wie die erde hat
dass er aussieht wie seine freunde oder
sonst was ist
ich verstehe das nicht ohne scheiß ich
verstehe nicht wie man sowas schreiben
kann als normaler mensch schreibt man so
was nicht und vor allem bleibt es nicht
ihr müsst einfach mal alles ein bisschen
hinterfragen ja ich habe zum beispiel
ein video war mir deshalb 730.000 klicks
oder so zurzeit klar es war auch nicht
so wirklich das beste video muss ich
sagen
aber dann habe ich auch kommentare unter
gelesen wo ich einfach ausschließlich
bleicht wurde und selbst ich mache mir
da schon die eine oder andere gedanken
bei wenn ich lese ja du bist ein kleiner
oder so gut bei mir ist das allerdings
so dass 90 prozent der leute mich feiern
und ein prozent fest feiern die kuppe
meine videos ganz gern und ein prozent
hat nicht ungefähr zwei wurf aber ok man
kann natürlich im internet hater aber
was mir dann so richtig auf den sack
geht wirklich richtig dass dieser typ so
krass viele menschen zum feiern bringen
keine ahnung dieser tat ihm der dem
kommentar ich würde niemals in seinem
ganzen leben auf der straße zu ihm
hingehen und das gleiche sagen
der wird nach dem foto fragen das ist
einfach so das ist bei jedem menschen so
und dann würde er wahrscheinlich noch
sagen ey du bist voll cool ich feiere
das was du machst weil das ist einfach
so ich verstehe nicht immer als mann zu
sein kann aber es ist so ich wurde noch
nie doch wirklich nie darauf
angesprochen von irgendwelchen fremde
menschen dass meine videos scheiße sind
oder sowas und das verstehe ich
überhaupt nicht mein ergeht in discos
bringt da 5000 leute zum abgeben und
jeder feiert ihn und im internet wird
aber fertig gemacht keinen sinn
das ergibt einfach keinen sinn diese
leute die in händen hält ihn wirklich
nur im internet und wenn sie dann halt
irgendwo auf der straße und lass mal
foto machen das egal wo bei laien ist
das wird bei gbs das so das ist einfach
so als nächstes beispiel noch ein guter
youtube kollege von mir ist auch mädchen
richtig sympathische person würde
niemals im leben irgendeinem menschen
beleidigt oder irgendwas zufügen keine
ahnung und zwar ist der prinz vielleicht
kennen ja an den kennt wahrscheinlich
auch viele von euch den prinzen kennt
man heimlich ja es halt einfach ein
bisschen anders aber unterhält so
wirklich mega viele leute ich war immer
jedes video das von dem puschlav mich
tot und das unterhält nicht wirklich
zehn minuten lang durchgehend ich denke
so nach zehn minuten hätte zehn minuten
schon vorbei ist man macht sein buch die
ganze zeit ist doch cool und bei ms
komplettes gleich unter den
youtube-videos da sehe ich auch so
kommentare wie die sind zum teil noch
viel schlimmer als bei dem beispiel eben
und zwar zum beispiel hier so ein
bastard ich schwöre bei gott wenn ich
dich draußen auf der straße begegnet
werde ich dich ab schlichen die
gebärmutter abfallprodukt das einzige
was du machen würdest zu ihm hingehen
und foto fragen oder ihr dunkel
verpiss dich von youtube und geht zurück
in einem schwulen szene oder einfach so
kommentare wie von wegen
komm du bist ein keine ahnung niemals in
eurem realen leben würde ich zu ihm
hingehen wenn ihr ihn sehen würde und
das gleiche sagen und genau das ist
einfach das was mich so richtig ankommt
ich meine klar in deutschland eher
spannungsfeld kannst von jedem die
meinung haben die du haben willst aber
bitte habt dann auch die eier im
reallife zum hin zu gehen und ihnen das
gleiche sagen was du im internet zu ihm
sagen würdest oder gesagt hast versteht
ihr ja so ist das halt leider ich weiß
auch nicht warum das ihr blaues ich habe
meine playstation portable an gemacht
schreibt eure mal zu dem ganzen weg und
in die kommentare gehöre das genauso
oder seid ihr auch leute die sowas
schreiben bitte sag einfach mal ehrlich
warum oder wenn ihr sowas mal
geschrieben habt dann schreib doch jetzt
mal warum wir das geschrieben hat oder
schreibt mir das nach dem video ein
bisschen bereut ich meine muss das so
verstehen können diese leute die haben
nichts die die versuchen leute zu
unterhalten und kriegen dafür sowas
zurück das ist einfach scheiße und ich
kenne das selber auch ein bisschen
deswegen überlegt zweimal auf wie diesen
kommentar verfasst oder nicht oder ob er
jetzt da das unterschreibt ihr wisst was
ich meine und anders wenn ich sagen wenn
das wieder einmal nach oben da jetzt hab
ich schon wieder zu schnell gesprochen
lediglich video gefeiert anlass auf
jeden fall noch um da ansonsten jetzt
freitag schon mit dem nächsten versuch
die auf keinen fall wasser
also schaut dass auf jeden fall anders
ist es wenn ich könnte mir gerne folgen
wenn ihr wollt hier oben links jetzt
weiter mit bayer im letzten video das
war hier von wegen im jahr kommen zehn
dinge die jeder kennt ihr schon mal
gemacht einen rat für mich freuen wir
sehen uns am nächsten freitag wieder am
start waren und jetzt ein live alex
schlage ich mich